on a fait le constat que la municipalité
actuelle dans son dernier mandat était
très peu à l'écouté des habitants et on
a souhaité du coup monté un mouvement à
l'occasion des élections municipales
pour essayer de proposer un autre projet
pour saint cyr l'école fonctionnement
horizontale donc notre idée en fait est
de construire le mouvement avec les
habitants et construit un programme avec
des habitants ont comparé de la base
c'est comme la construction en fait
d'une maison on a commencé d'abord par
les fondations et ensuite petit à petit
on rassemble des habitants autour de
nous pour console d'avoir un programme
et puis peu à peu on va aller jusqu'au
toit on a cinq grandes thématiques pour
le programme démocratie et souveraineté
locales services publics activité
économique et culturelle environnement
et transition écologique et solidarité
et vie associative
j'invite du coup tous les saints
syrienne et les saint cyriens à venir
mercredi 6 novembre donc à 20 heures à
la salle des fêtes pour venir participer
à la co construction d'un programme pour
la ville